Quietly and praying there
was goodness to it. Yeah.
And they went out and fed the homeless.
There was good stuff that came from it.
And she wants that. I get that. And now
you're sitting in an institution though,
then you know the backstory
of what's going on. It's,
you know, how do you sit
there? How do you sit there?
So I said to her last name,
I wish just go to yoga will
satisfy your spiritual side.
But, but you know, wacky
too, man. I mean, no, look,
I go to a Bikram Yoga,
I go to hot yoga. Yeah.
90 minute hot yoga.
And that guy,
I don't think he's allowed to come
in in this country. No, he's not.
The guy who made big room
now, now that guy, he's, he,
he,
he got a little rapey.
Well he definitely got a little,
he took advantage of his privilege,
his position, our, well, yeah,
I guess you could say power,
but the reverence that people had towards
him, they felt like he was a guru.
And so he would get these girls alone
and he would make them suck his deck or
whatever. Right. But I think,
see now this I'm getting,
this is very dangerous waters,
but I was having a conversation
with a woman who is a,
she's an actually an instructor,
and she said, listen,
that guy is definitely creepy,
but let me tell you something.
A lot of those girls not
only knew what he was about,
but they wanted to be with him.
They wanted to be with him because of
his power and because he represented
something special to them.
And then when he just shot a load in their
mouth and then kicked him to the curb,
then they became angry and
decided that they were molested.
They went into it willingly. I do not
know if she's accurate or inaccurate.
I was not there and I'm not a woman,
but I do know that people have like, uh,
like I remember women throwing,
not throwing themselves,
but making it very clear that they were,
they had deep admiration for my
martial arts instructor when I was,
when I was a young kid and I
was a practicing taekwondo.
I remember these women,
they were so in awe of my martial arts
instructor because he represented the
master of something that they
were deeply enamored by it.
And I think that's also what happens with
these yoga people. Yeah, it's seductive.
Yes. You know, it's seductive.
You know, there's an,
and also with something like that, it's
very physical and mental and spiritual.
It's sexual. Sexual Yoga is, I don't,
I've never had any sex with
anybody in my yoga class, but,
but I'm telling you when everybody's
in there sweating and everyone's almost
naked,
I'm wearing these little fucking shorts
and then the girls are wearing these
little shorts and, and the teacher
goes around and she like calls you out.
It's like, oh, she likes me.
Understand how some of those people get
intimate with each other after this is
all over because they're so close to naked
and sweating together. Right. You know,
and your friend is right in that there,
there were some women I'm sure
who wanted to be with him. Yes.
But he's not dismissing
any rap shit either.
But it's his responsibility because
he has the power and knows what he's
wielding like in a
workplace kind of thing.
It's up to you to be the one
who puts the brakes on it.
That's where it gets interesting.
Yes.
He does not seem to think that he does
have any responsibility at all for the
people that are working for him teaching
these classes and cha like he was,
he did this HBO documentary. It
was fucking, they did this HBO,
a interview about him. It
was so ridiculous. This is
the Bikram guy. Yeah. Yeah.
He goes,
did a woman that would pay $1
million for one drop of my sperm.
He says this CV can find the video,
so he's fully aware.
I'm saying he's fucking crazy. He's
fully aware of his power. Crazy.
He was.
He was dismissing the idea that he
would ever sexually assaulted anyone.
He's like,
why would I do that when these women that
will pay $1 million for one drop of my
spam? Well, it wasn't about why it wasn't.
Yeah,
it wasn't Bryant Gumbel wasn't there.
I think they're discussing it. Right.
They're discussing this. Correct. Comment,
you gone to see the guy
because he looks like a cause.
He said the comment to a woman and
she was like this. She was like,
what in the fuck did you say?
You know,
like Hbo Shows Very Andrea Kramer breaks
down million dollar sperm interview
some shit that you said.
There's some shit that you say when
people go, wait, what the fuck?
Holy Shit. Yeah. There's some
things that are what's causing that.
You would call beyond the Pale. Yeah.
Well, I love, I love just seeing pictures.
You hear these stories, then you see him,
he's like, you're like grandpa. He's like,
oh, loose skinned. And he's
balding. But that's the thing.
It's like when you're in a power
of a powerful position like that,
he's very spiritual and
people will pay $1 million.
What does it say from being
circumspect and real sport? Uh,
the seven year old went off on a rant
claiming 5,000 women a day want to sleep
with him for,
have committed suicide over his charms
and people would pay $1 million for a
drop of his sperm.
See now if you lived in that world,
I would just shoot loads every
day and then retire. If you,
if you just drank eight,
a lot of zinc.
A lot of zinc and like what makes
loads. Oysters, celery. Yeah.
Is that Vegan nonsense now began,
does that person, those people are,
he adds to the pop. Who tells
you that? The salary people.
That's like, that's like some fucking
salary lobby. No, it's true. Celery does.
How do you know? I remember
I read something. Porn
people, right? Salary. Yes.
Salary. If you know
what's Jamie Gadea. Oh,
the most beautiful, famous,
rich women in the world.
If have to sleep with women
and have to sleep. No,
by thousand garland every day she cried.
Thousand women a day.
Want to sleep with you?
Two. Sorry. Four of them.
You're just saying that for
different women, for different women,
each killed themselves because you
wouldn't have sex all night. Why?
I am the head.
I sit women people's been
$1 million per one drum.
Pop my sperm million dollar day.
Every drop that idiot or dumb to believe
those trash to women at the trash.
Yeah,
I big them palm trash and give them life.
Oh my God. 70 years old. He looks
pretty good for a 70 year old.
That's what I'm selling. All that
loads. Uh Oh my God. It's so good.
Don't last very long. They got to get it
dry up real quick. Yeah, they get gross.
Do you know what man? Oh Man. Yeah. So
that spiritual thing, like the goals,
but that's, yeah. Yeah.
It's like the problem with it is
you're still an animal, right?
So if the animal, it's like
we were talking about before
where the wolves gone,
these surplus kills and they kill all
these elk and they don't eat them. Yeah.
I'll get in Wyoming,
there was a recent issue,
there was 18 elk that were
killed by wolves and these
surplus killings is a real
tragedy. Yeah. These walls can't help
themselves. It's just their instincts.
So his instincts as a man, he has
instincts to procreate, right.
His instincts to respond to women
that are sexually attracted to him.
And he teaches these classes in front
of hundreds and thousands of people and
everybody loves and adores him. So
when he is fucked up, twisted brain,
everything that he said there made sense.
My favorite part of it was that woman
Andrea, when she, when she clarified. Yes.
So you're saying, you're saying that
for women have committed to it like,
I want this motherfucker has to be clear
as nonsense. I like she's there is,
she doesn't even change her expression.
She's just like, so you're saying? Yeah.
I mean,
look at that girl right now.
He's standing on top of a woman's
hips as she's bent over backwards.
That girl is like, he wants
me, he standing over me.
This is way I've taken a
lot of yoga classes. Nobody
ever sitting on my hips now,
hey bro.
But I do like it when you're doing yoga
and they come over and they like push
your legs down and you're like, yeah, a
little, it's a little stretching. Oh Shit.
I just spelled.